they sense a shift in the governance of
northern ireland a political earthquake
for the united kingdom
[Applause]
the result raises the prospect of a vote
on irish unity
shin fein on course to nominate a first
minister
well there's still a way to go yet david
but obviously it's a very significant
election for many reasons and
the people have responded to our
positive campaign a very positive
message and it's now time to get almost
permanent executive and delivering for
people
the sea border between great britain and
northern ireland the consequence of
brexit has fractured the unionist vote
but the democratic unionists were not
conceding defeat they know there can't
be a power sharing government without
them we need the long shadow of the
protocol removed from the political
institutions in northern it is creating
untold harm to northern ireland and it
needs to be dealt with and it must be
dealt with and the government need to
hear that message very loud and clear
shinton did better than it could
the dup not as badly as it feared
[Applause]
one of the big stories of this election
is the quiet revolution that's taking
place in the middle ground while it's
clear many people are still voting along
traditional lines a growing number are
choosing not to vote unionist or
nationalist but for a completely new
type of politics here
the alliance party could double its
representation a clear signal from a
weary electorate precious little hope um
available for people at the minute it's
been a pretty grim couple of years and
the politics has been pretty grim to
match it we just offered people i think
hope that things could be better and
that's what we want to deliver on
brexit had already placed the
constitutional question on the table but
will shin fan now demand a referendum on
irish unity
the conversation around the unity place
has been
forced right into the four for quite a
considerable period of time that was
always going to be the outcome that's
going to continue the other side of this
election regardless of the outcome if
northern ireland has elected a first
minister whose party doesn't want
northern ireland to exist
it's a defining moment
david blevins sky news in belfast